¿Es 3, -4 una solución a la ecuación
"5x" más "2y" igual a 7?
Nos están preguntando si
"x" igual a 3 y "y" igual a -4
cumplen con esta ecuación
cumplen con esta relación que tenemos aquí.
Lo que vamos a hacer entonces es sustituir
"x" igual a 3 "y" igual a -4 en esta ecuación
y ver si efectivamente
"5x" más "2y" es igual a 7
tenemos entonces que
5 por 3 más 2 por -4
esto es igual a 5 por 3 = 15
más 2 por -4
más -8
y esto es efectivamente igual a 7
así es que si es una solución,
ese punto está en la recta
"x" igual a 3 y "y" igual a -4
efectivamente satisfacen esta ecuación.
hemos respondido a la pregunta,
sí es solución.
Otra manera de hacer esto,
no voy a entrar en los detalles pero,
lo que puedes hacer de hecho,
es graficar la línea
supongamos que la línea fuera algo así
no voy a entra en los detalles pero,
lo que tendrías que hacer es ver si el punto
se ubica sobre la línea
si el punto efectivamente está sobre
la línea es una solución
y si no está sobre la línea
no es una solución.
Pero para hacer esto tienes que
hacer un dibujo muy preciso
y así determinar si efectivamente
el punto está sobre la línea.
Si usas el método de sustitución
y al sustituir los valores en la ecuación verificas
que hay una validez matemática en dicha ecuación,
esto es un método preciso.
Esto era lo que necesitábamos hacer,
todo lo que necesitábamos hacer en este ejemplo
para verificar que efectivamente,
sí es una solución.